>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
PULLED OFF A DIPLOMATIC COUP IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS, PLAYING HOST
TO FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON.
FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP HAS
ENGINEERED HER OWN DIPLOMATIC
TRIUMPH RECENTLY.
FIRST AS A DIGNIFIED WHITE HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVE AT THE BARBARA
BUSH FUNERAL THIS WEEKEND AND
THEN OVER THE LAST TWO DAYS AS
THE FLAWLESS HOSTESS OF THE
FRENCH FIRST FAMILY.
INCLUDING AT TONIGHT'S STATE
DINNER.
MAYBE MELANIA WILL FINALLY GET
SOME OF THOSE MAGAZINE COVERS
THAT FEATURED MICHELLE OBAMA SO
PROMINENTLY AND FREQUENTLY.
BUT I WON'T HOLD MY BREATH.
TO DISCUSS WHERE ALL OF THIS, WE
ARE JOINED BY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RACHEL CAMPOS DUFFY
ALONG WITH THE PUBLISHER OF
CATALINA MAGAZINE, CATHY AREU.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
LET'S START WITH YOU, RACHEL.
MELANIA HAS HAD TO ENDURE
JIMMY KIMMEL, MOCKING HER
ACCENT.
I KNOW YOU APOLOGIZE.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT YOU KNOW, SHE'S NOT GOTTEN
THE COVER OF "VOGUE" FIVE TIMES
IN THE FIRST YEAR LIKE MICHELLE.
I'M EXAGGERATING BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING.
SHE HAS BEEN
SCRUTINIZED.
THE SHE'S HOLDING HER HUSBAND'S
HAND OR NOT.
IT'S UNLESS.
YET TONIGHT WE SEE A BEAUTIFUL
DINNER THAT SHE DID NOT HIRE OR
AN EVENT PLANNER FOUR.
SHE DID IT ALL HERSELF.
ALL THE DESIGN, ALL OF THE
SELECTION.
NO DESIREE ROGERS HELPING HER.
>> I MEAN, REMEMBER SHE WAS A
SOCIALITE.
WE ASSUMED WHEN SHE WAS
MRS. TRUMP LIVING IN MANHATTAN
SHE PROBABLY HOSTED MANY EVENTS.
THIS IS HER SHOWCASING WHAT SHE
BRINGS TO THE OFFICE OF
FIRST LADY.
OR THE POSITION OF FIRST LADY.
I WOULD SAY THAT WHILE THIS HAS
BEEN AN AMAZING EVENT AND IT HAS
BEEN FLAWLESS, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT ABOUT THAT, LAURA, SHE'S
BEEN DOING THIS ALL ALONG.
I'VE BEEN SO IMPRESSED WITH NOT
JUST HER QUIET DIGNITY, AS YOU
BROUGHT UP, BUT ALSO JUST THIS
DIPLOMATIC USE OF FASHION.
IT'S BEEN BRILLIANT WHEN SHE
WENT TO PARIS AND TO THAT
RESTAURANT AT THE EIFFEL TOWER.
SHE WAS WEARING RED, WHITE, AND
BLUE, A SYMBOL OF BOTH LEGS.
SHE WORE THAT GORGEOUS BLACK
CAFTAN WITH THE GOLD IN
SAUDI ARABIA.
WHO CAN FORGET THE AMAZING ASIAN
INSPIRED GOWN SHE WORE IN CHINA
WITH THE PINK.
SHE IS BEEN DOING THIS ALL
ALONG.
I HAVE TO SAY ALSO.
YOU ARE RIGHT.